würdest du mit youtube aufhören wenn du
deine traumfrau bekommen könnte
außer es geht und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft legend level
mit dem logischen folge helfen und wir
können direkt mal auf dem kleinen server
drauf wir haben in der letzten folge
jahr einen dia gefunden leute nicht die
us sondern ein leider nur ein
aber immerhin bin ich ja ich keine
fehler mache auch muss man auch musst da
nachts um drei macht kleinvieh musst und
nicht mehr mit euch das für die zukunft
da drüben waren gerade eben was keine
eben für euch der letzten folge
wir nehmen ein bisschen am stück auf
drei folgen und produzieren so kleines
bisschen vor das eigentlich einen kurzen
managen und glaube ich wissen die
meisten leute gar nicht können wir ein
bisschen erzählen dass wir einfach aus
dem ganzen projekt zehn folgen
zurückgehen es gibt leute die sind
meilenweit vor uns aber auch teilweise
ganz seltsam also leute laden irgendwie
40 minuten folgen wo ich mir denke warum
wieso mit welcher rechtfertigung und
wieder auszugleichen quasi man hat ja
eine woche upload und sowas aber das
machen wir alles nicht wird er einfach
nur unseren weg durch das projekt und
komme mir eigentlich wir sind ja auch
noch im rennen das muss man ja sagen
oder wie oder gemacht eine 40 minuten
folge in dem wir uns noch ein bisschen
mehr nach vorne teleportieren
diese nach vorne bringen wir das wollte
in meinem leben kriege ich die hochbau
im internet dann lobt die einfach nicht
hoch
die zuschauer von oben können sich dann
vorstellen dass die 440 minuten
zuschauen
und dann
äpfel ich habe einen film im topos
köpfen machen tolle überleitungen haben
hat er gerade ein mister morgen in bonn
ein
als ok als ob dies auf kommende noch
kein leben wieso habt ihr im namen und
wann werdet ihr gegen das beste team
anymore sterben entlang läuft müsste
morgen erstmal ge an dich dass du so
spät dran bist wo ist denn unser achter
ist retweets kannst kannst du mir wie
ich einfach jede frage kannst du mir
anfangen ich kann einfach gar nicht
selbst kräftig genug sie wollen wir
diese frage beantworten müsste morgen
sind die einzelne dich finde ich auch
noch töten müsste mord ein cooler muss
man sagen nimmt manchmal den mund bis
hin zur voll cool homo wir werden mal
schauen wir machen unser ding und
vielleicht begegnet man sich irgendwann
mal sogar ziemlich wahrscheinlich dann
werden wir natürlich unser bestes geben
und versuchen
wusstest du dass ich übrigens das buch
weiter für jede folge sein kurzen
eintrag schreibe was für süss mehr süße
jemanden dem logo vorbeischauen in der
beschreibung der leichter lassen wir ja
auch fan dass es süß ist oder einfach
nur fleisch waschen
ich sollte vielleicht mal ein bisschen
zu sorgen mal jetzt übrigens schon am
ersten feld abschnitt das einzige was
wir jetzt noch brauchen uns wasser
perfekt hier kommt jetzt erde in wie
findet man hier nicht so die krassen die
das habe ich gefühlt
okay da hin dass er mich sogar
natürliche kühle obwohl die schon
abgefahren
wahrscheinlich schon ich habe ihr noch
eisen im inventar perfekt wo komme ich
jetzt hier kam jetzt hierher ja darum
ist ein bisschen euren reisen läuft bei
uns einfach verein habe das hier sieht
einfach die höhe aus wie die höhe der
wir den wupsi fanden gefunden haben
leute finden wir nicht also da hinten
häufig glück richtig kritisch aus das
liegt es liegt ja auch alles in einem
höhlensystem zusammen ist es ja bei uns
richtig also angeblich haben wir den
schatz des wupsi fanden nicht gefunden
leute ja also irgendwie wir haben es
irgendwie kanada und ein führer
versteckt viele leute regen sich heute
noch darüber aber keine ahnung wie
wüssten nicht was was einfach war muss
erscheint jetzt ohne scheiß wir wissen
es nicht wir wissen das echt nicht nur
was wir keine ahnung haben
wir sind unschuldige kleine boys und
wissen nicht was der schotte fanden das
stimmt dass irgendwas perversen das war
besser das ist nicht gefunden hat es
wird riesig da waren weit war dass
richtiges höhen system dahinter wo sie
über die perverse vergewaltiger höhle
lag stets auf die ganze zeit diese
seltsamen höhlensystem bassist peter
appel jeder nicht rein wir haben uns
schon dreimal verlaufen jetzt sich
jedoch nicht rein
ich gehe doch gar keinen fall rein muss
auch besser zusammen wenn wir gelernt
aus unseren fehlern aber jetzt auch ein
bisschen zu gut
wie sieht es mit dem weizenfeld aus man
gerade an ich bin auch relativ gewaltig
mache gerade die einteilung jetzt gerade
noch fertig hier wo ich die wasser den
rhein setzte um hier dann gleich noch
zuckerrohr anzubauen
ich zucke haben wir aber ich glaube kein
sand werden da muss ich erde nehmen
haben wir haben nicht zu ihr habe ich
doch mitgenommen
der williams-mann ohne wir noch ein paar
weitere fragen liefern ist er geradezu
mister x der recht nervende nachts um 3
zurück irgendwas zu antworten
jetzt weiß ich auch nicht so viele volle
auftrat ist echt dran in der sache nacht
zum 30
schwierige frage die vor allem im jahr
die die jetzt auch eine sehr wichtige
frage ist wenn es schon spät auf dem
auch motive fragen machen würdest du mit
youtube aufhören wenn du deine traumfrau
bekommen könntest dafür dass mit youtube
aufhöre
ja also die quasi seine seelenverwandte
die perfekte ich würde sagen man
tendiert immer mehr zum jahr ihr
verzweifelter mann ist ich persönlich
bin ein typ der eigentlich leuten ist
mal wieder ein krüper geile sache hier
ja danke ist tot
ich persönlich bin jemand der eigentlich
für beziehung eigentlich zu haben es so
aber auch überhaupt kein problem damit
hat single zu sein
manche fans ganz still ich dann so war
dann aber wieder so eigentlich ganz gut
auch mal single zu sein
ohne witz ich kriege so viel scheiße mit
von irgendwelchen freundinnen die dann
ihren freunden erzählen wollen wie die
ihr leben leben sollen irgendwelche und
irgendwie bieten in ihren hobbys
nachzugehen da denke ich mir so gott sei
dank bis die single alter aber nachdem
es ist beides cool die beiden klar kommt
und ich würde sagen
momentan könnte ich vielleicht noch
vorstellen aber ich weiß nicht
hier hat dem wenn es dann irgendwie mal
weiter wächst wenn man premier gaddafi
bauen mit megaphon online wenn es dann
weiter wächst irgendwann ist aber so ein
wichtiger teil ist es jetzt schon für
mich also ich hab da hab jetzt schon so
viel herzblut reingesteckt
ich glaub dir mal kurz die bei uns nennt
man das manöver 98 anwenden was
ladekabel ins tablet stecken commercials
kurz droppen
doch es hält jetzt einfach so du hast
falls emmental glaube ich auch
alter hier drüben ist einfach eine gute
frage wie findest du es dass du jetzt
youtube aufgabe hast hast du ja schon
ein bisschen länger als ich dann könnte
man einfach jetzt glaube ich schon nicht
mehr letzter zeit momentan diesen 18
back dass man dass die dich ja im kern
gelegten modus einfach sehen ja ja
irgendwie es gibt also nicht bei kauf
komme was nicht weniger cool ist aber
die youtuber letztlich darf als ich ein
ganz vorne an der so wie soll man sagen
mit der heutigen der kritiker sturm
hoffe ich der erste der immer fleißig
dabei ist wie sozusagen ein mit plug in
ist nicht gut macht das besser klar
dafür auch er macht ja auch selbst sehr
gute sachen stück viel arbeit rein an
programm das die leute da ähnlich
professionell sind kann ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen wie gesagt mensch weißt
du kannst ab gerade nachts um drei worte
ich bin sowieso und abschalten das thema
youtuber status aufkommen war einfach so
graf für mich hat gefeiert sachen ein
paar schöne sachen an kopf geworfen wie
sie werden euch in den boden stampfen
darüber aber vielleicht sind darauf zu
verwertende fragen
stichwort anymore wird siegen falls es
so ist cool
wir werden auf jeden fall nicht so
spielen dass es ihnen leicht macht man
wenn es denn so schwer machen wie
möglich
falls es trotzdem so ist dann ja cool
dann wäre es irgendwie verdient haben
ich werde dich trotzdem ne peas und
hacks schreiben
so bin ich halt leute so bin ich aber
ihre reben sind er ich weiß schon eine
weile keine diesmal gefunden das trifft
man sich doch ob diese wunderschöne
ziehen die meisten tore
was kommt noch was kommt was haben wir
hier noch ist der tvi vermisst
der wunderbare unternehmen noch ein paar
fragen von mary hätte so schöne gestellt
jetzt da war hat eine richtig vorsicht
fragen beantwortet grüßt dich mary mary
gaddafi was würdet ihr machen wenn ihr
kein youtube machen könnte ganzen tag
motto bio gerade mein netzwerk supporter
freuen
er schaut nämlich meine videos und das
freut ihn immer solche solche begriffe
zu hören ok dann sollte ein bisschen
mehr brocken vom schauen für alle die
auf diese netzwerk abhängig aber größer
hallo
generell hält sich an wie kasseroler das
gehirn ist ein flüssiger kakao milch die
irgendwie dazwischen den schädel wänden
hin und her oszilliert und schwarzen
nichts logisches produzieren kann
aber irgendwie kann ich jetzt mehr als
vor bald aufzunehmen was meine tastatur
auch findet und das mit einem fröhlichen
gang in das pausen menü ausdrückt und
signalisiert wir drücken weiter fest
gesehen super typ
welches haustier würdet ihr am liebsten
haben
ein hund auf jeden fall sagt ich so
liebe hunde
wir hatten noch mal meine oma hatte mein
hund runde sind loyale brüder sagt ja
nicht umsonst madox so etwas ab doch ich
bin da können wir den ganzen tag mit
sprache bringen mein hund wäre also der
krasseste hut google und will einfach
bei allem down sein jemanden so ich
würde da natürlich gangster mit
irgendwas autofahren so bringt lassmann
panamera turbo seinem bescheidenen hasen
panamera turbo und er mein hund hinten
so aus dem fenster mit einer schönen
basecap irgendwie 100 base cap oder
platz im krimi clip blatt keine ahnung
irgendwie so gekleidet gang mäßig helfen
glaube ich das geräusch war es ein
krieger aus dem osten wunderbar ich war
einfach mein ganzes leben dann kommt es
dann ab und es kommt exakt endlich mal
ein loch
ich bin sebastian gemacht habe wo wie
was okay orientierung ist eine [ __ ] und
nicht so leicht zu bekommen nicht klar
ich sag's euch ist aber lustig
meine zeit ist natürlich dass man sagt
so was und dann wachen menschen ja das
ist einfach um die uhrzeit nicht lustig
ich hoffe ihr lacht ich hoffe ihr seid
ich hoffe euch euer spiel video spricht
genug was ihr auf unseren weib hier
irgendwie kommt wie sie zu dem feld
drüben auswächst angelegt und ich mache
jetzt hier so weitere abschnitte fertig
ich hab mir gab abgab wir können in der
nächsten folge waren die oberfläche
gehen und vielleicht wisst ihr was man
diesen kleinen trick müssen wir nicht
wir haben alles da was wir brauchen und
können jetzt die ganze zeit aussahen und
die nächsten so kann man ja mal fragen
ob das mal droppen weil das ist doch
viel chilliger und so können wir uns das
jetzt die letzte chance ist auch zu
erklären es noch drei leben das bedeutet
jeder von uns kann auch ein respawn und
dann noch einer und das wäre dann
wirklich es clever er besser im pvp es
lassen wir ihnen wie es bauen noch mal
ran gebilde auch fackeln widmete
deswegen lassen wir ihn respawn und erst
noch versuchen was zu reißen
deswegen finde ich es besser wenn jetzt
eine base ausbauen und dann wie quasi
benutzen ist überall einfach dixence
rektorin der wand manche ab level wie
ein bastard alter richtige rich
negativlauf in die richtige richtung
natürlich war es die falsche leute steht
vollkommen außer frage und das immer so
schnell voll mitmischen kobel scheiß und
schmidt stone dem stone den man haben
will man sich so fühlt als kommissar
ganz ehrlich niemand will koppel stone
ja unser lager ist wird langsam es wird
richtig schön gerade hier hast du schon
ein bisschen du kannst ein bisschen
knochenmehl darauf wollen ja habe ich
dann habe ich schon herb schon gepusht
aber schon ein bisschen brot rausgeholt
wie viel butter zucker ich habe zu neuen
brotes entspannte sache ja wir könnten
nämlich in der nächsten folge war weiß
wie man fährt dafür dass wir in der
nächsten folge jetzt wo die folge ehe
vorbei ist jetzt beide mal hier ich nehm
die richtung hier die ihr oder ich kann
auch in die richtung da vorne gehen und
bei hier gänge nun teil die auf und du
gehst in die andere richtung dann dort
nach dorthin wollen wir vielleicht
einfach mal was sie da hinten ist auch
noch wasser wenn man das auch noch holen